okay that's fine that's fine then don't
give me an ADD yes please keep messaging
me that was not the time cool okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you might want to move over a little bit
hey actually should play with
[Music]
yo what's up
[Music]
go right into a jig for that volume
hey everyone sorry we had some technical
difficulties right now he can't see us
at the moment but my name is Jake I'm
here with John Luke we are going to play
the first 90 minutes of Mario once again
sorry we're late hopefully you guys can
hear us cuz like I said I've been having
some technical difficulties but yeah
this is gonna be the first 90 minutes
sick about give or take Laura ow bring
that volume up for this
[Music]
just get right to it huh yeah
SiC
Oh No
I know it starts out kind of dark right
this our Wolfenstein which games is more
dark this for sure
I haven't played Wolfenstein yet but
this I mean we're getting this area
black and white oh yeah definitely so I
played a little bit last night so I know
to expect right now but this is your
very first time look around
yes yeah you actually just got it in the
mail today mm-hmm smells fresh I am
playing with the joint kind of separated
the game recommended that is how you
should play because it's got the motion
yeah it definitely makes it easier I
only played in handheld last night
someone is asking where's the camera
like I said we're having some technical
difficulties we're still here but we're
gonna leave it on gameplay because I
think that's a little bit more
interesting than us
we apologize hopefully next week we'll
get all this sorted out the motherboard
on our old streaming PC gave out right
as we were about together literally ten
minutes before we're starting but yeah
if you guys have any questions feel free
to drop it in the comments or the chat
I'll be looking at all that and
gentlemen we'll be playing do you want
to see them do funny things as Mario its
goodies here for hope we can get some
sweet costumes that's all that's all
everyone's been talking about the
costumes it meets the nature of our job
but I've unfortunately had all the
costumes spoiled for me yeah which is
because I would have liked to move some
of those yeah so we are meeting Kathy
his sister's been kidnapped John and
Jake actually playing on switch
playing yes yeah yeah yeah this is like
Mario 64 and HD and more advanced uh
yeah I mean it seems like it
structurally it seems yeah is this on pc
no it is not looks pretty damn good
though dies like it's almost too much
detail for Mario because of the tempered
style they use in these games
yeah they don't they don't really need
to push it much further right even
though the switch is technically less
powerful than ps3 and xbox one and you
know the Xbox one X is coming out now
with 4k and all that right perfect
although grammar warriors have a little
bit of trouble running on so yeah maybe
the one thing would be like it'd be nice
if the smoke oh yeah
skip Mario all nice and toasty music is
very uh Marcus says I just bought it for
70 US dollars how did you buy it for
Saturday I'm doing like I'm shaking
right now
obviously all these Trixie in there
yeah it'll teach you as you go aqua
ninjas says is this you guys's favorite
Mario game best far John Luke is two
minutes in may yeah I played about
thirty minutes last night so it's really
hard to tell I have been recently
replaying all the Mario games so for a
history of video yeah
would you say your favorite is I played
them all before with the exception of
sunshine which I'd never played I
actually really liked it yeah I know a
lot of people don't like that game or
feel it doesn't pull up so it's kind of
worried about it but something down
there total gaming HD says I'm a new
viewer well thank you for stopping by
and then I can't it's it's as far as it
goes really awesome let's talk louder
hey everyone how's it going
[Music]
flick-flick joy Khan's up or down at the
same time for the controls yeah
something ridiculous like then
apparently you only need like 100
[Music]
Oh looky going wet shining he looks like
a looking at me bow
[Music]
okay
[Music]
you're gonna leave that box off like
don't do the fuse on those you have to
break the boxes it's crazy to think you
guys a full Zelda game this year and a
full good your friend out Miller here
Jessica Bennett says dammit why am i
watching something that will make me
want the switch looks like it's worth it
well thank you for watching first of all
second of all I feel like most console
watches I could hi I can easily
recommend like add is wait a year you
know typically it takes a year before a
lot of good games come out for like a
new system right or it feels like it's
worth it it hasn't even been a full year
and already I'm like dude you should buy
a switch like I I have a suspicion I
think it's the common one but I think
Nintendo is finish this game a while ago
and he's kind of waiting for the right
time
yeah although the although I'm sure yeah
do that as a trip a lot of people sing
they're getting lag now a lot of people
come people in both twitch and YouTube
are a lot of people getting lag okay
currently Millerton says I'm getting a
switch which holiday hopefully yeah my
fingers are crossed I hope you get one
as well we're saying that FPS FPS if you
saw it on our end mario is tripping
yeah mario is
[Music]
so Nintendo realize
corazon says leggy this is a kind of
gamer well I do like knowing our be
surprised I'd be worried about streaming
a star's life yeah they had like a week
and a half early - it's driving me crazy
[Music]
busting through that door
let's go I think one of my favorite
Mario jumps is the VR and like hey
Naughty Dog is in the chat they say no
face cam laying yeah sorry had some
technical difficulties we'll get it
sorted when laughter sleeping that we
strain that my face cam by then do you
think it's a weird coincidence that
there's like rabid enemies in this game
and Mario rabbits came out this year
[Music]
[Music]
0o are like hit him outside possessing
how's he gonna be gonna have to do that
[Music]
[Music]
you're playing in Japanese Japanese I
don't think there is I mean the text is
English but I'm pretty sure all the
actual speaking is just like gibberish
there's many options
I can't even click anything yet shake it
Oh keep shaking keep shaking there we
got the leg guys probably you know some
of the chats saying that they're having
no issues we'll keep an eye on guys that
we want to make sure everyone's yeah I
mean tastes said a couple days ago that
like you know I mean there's only so
much we can do on our end
[Music]
sometimes just issues our internet from
twitch chooses accuser YouTube right
total gaming says my dad loves your vids
who's miners on this vote game sponges
nothing
first power moon yeah
you know I mean you kind of do have to
but like I played for a while last night
not using I just played handheld mode
but yeah there were certain things or
it's like do this and I was like I can't
do this right now
oh wait
any wooden oh I miss that
coming capture an entrepreneur app shoot
came from a coming town forever we have
the five Hudson RDC oh that be
yeah let's go
it's like see that out yeah well Mariama
katsu
[Music]
yes
I love
yeah with that moon all the music in
this game is so good so far yes
[Music]
[Music]
first power moon good work do you they
should port the galaxy games that'd be
really cool cuz you can do it because
those games don't have mushrooms outside
of the second fire service
[Music]
Chain Chomp man this really is like 64
except instead when you get a thing yeah
I was actually talking about that this
morning
I was thing about this morning is how
like this is very nice I don't get a
jump back to me I don't think it would
make sense the way that babe there's
like those games and sunshine who's only
67 this seems like there's just so many
yeah yeah pretty girls but actually
bothered me in those games is who would
like died and then it would put you out
of the painting and it's like I'm just
gonna go right back in like why are you
making me like looks like someone is
spamming the chat hey if you're watching
maybe you can
Reiner Brian or minor bad oh yeah looks
like it's on YouTube
for more
oh that looks like that yeah it's like
at an angle
good
I think this is the one to play this
[Music]
it looks nice on you but yeah it does
consider the Kindle screen is really
good plus something about the shaking
would be awful yeah that's what I was
saying like I just didn't do it I just
like found other means things with my
cap the lazy gamer gaming to give this
game in five hours
see that's the thing is like after the
screen you know I've got so much editing
to do after this
[Music]
[Music]
there's so much detail on these things
oh yeah like it looks like a glass
smashing things
[Music]
Ilia they're just people to t-rex right
I know
[Music]
I'm not too fond of everything but I
hope
with a jerk so with the races yeah that
one that always
whoa whoa what just happened
there's like a bounce oh it is
smashed it going brush everything
oh okay at the time we can go back to it
[Music]
can we please get an open-world Metroid
like Odyssey and death of the wild but I
if you need to make a Metroid game that
wasn't in the style of a Metroidvania
and they're kind of open as is right
[Music]
do the spin think that was mario art
[Music]
that's true
[Music]
I forgot to get behind the folder
[Music]
[Music]
just reminder if you guys have any
questions please let us know in the
comments we started a little bit late
today however normally we stream Monday
through Friday at 11 a.m. Pacific
usually just whatever game is hot
whatever game were interested in today
we're doing Mario we were torn between
Mario and Wolf and fans we think we're
just better because to spoilers yeah
that's so cool okay
I like the look of this game
[Music]
BAM
[Applause]
[Music]
start
[Music]
oh yeah yes I
[Music]
do LZ and jump on you do that there's an
artsy word
is this game worth the name of Canadian
dollars i stumped the pre-order
I mean movie played enough to
necessarily say but Peter gave it a 10
here gave it a 10 guys let's say we've
got a review not only did James I get a
ton but think about plug in here like a
9.5
[Music]
let's go back okay oh there we go
there you go
[Music]
like how the music changes yeah it's
like retro
very good
[Music]
nice grabs right back on
you should try to get a smack into that
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
oh no not you out of it yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
like they're dead there's no way they
can survive I was thinking about that
like 60 and i-64 galaxy you're fighting
this like baby
[Music]
I just like that baby right
[Music]
cool Multi moon all right well I should
have more than enough then you need a
five right how many do you have
I think I have enough for or but you got
want to be turning to
yeah here we go ready let's do it
[Music]
[Music]
milah Jordan says she abused the chomp
we had to set it free it's true
I mean Mario kind of does too
he basically possesses them and turns
them against each other okay we're just
going right to it keep going we'll come
back here later I know yeah you did
that's okay like I feel like
that's how I did in the other one he's
one Akali
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
I want to get some new dog city I don't
know if we're good there about how far
that is or anything but oh there's this
really great see if I can get it I have
to let the controller set for a minute
but Mario will like fall asleep it's
been like 30 minutes in no Kenya as I
said before unfortunately we had some
technical difficulties this morning and
we didn't have time to get the camera
set up basically the the motherboard on
the old streaming PC just died so we had
to swap something in and set up new
cameras here we're here but we figured
you guys rather see the gameplay than us
okay just tell me like basic actions I
think I got it for now but Mario game
course
okay let's steal a wedding ring sounds
like sounds like fun
I want to get some alternate costumes
for the first stories here sweet you
probably been up going to get something
but if you want like area-specific you
need the purple ones for here make sense
also if you hold still
Mario is very cold let me be hot no see
look at all the ice it's not supposed to
be so cold do their sit-down thing let's
give it a second
so how far in the game are you I have
about four or five moons here so I'm not
much farther at all you just wash it
down might be a tease - cold cold filled
sleeping this cookie try later it's
pretty good though
this dress
I like the texture shaking is really
good yo there's a sheep she's making him
do tricks
yeah that is so good he's got a cowboy
hat because it's why the F knot yeah
they take coins they take one special go
just gonna bind the nose you can but I
don't think you can continue to buy
moons so boxer shorts these don't have
enough of that I thought those were swim
trunks I thought they were too no
apparently Meyer just runs around
I prefer boxer shorts they should buy
the employee uniform I'm gonna save up
for the boxes I'd save up for the boxer
shorts then use your other kinds of that
except we don't have any other courtesy
we can get okay yeah oh it's not a whole
lot I want the I want the the cowboy
Mario I don't know huh there's a sticker
oh I think you can put that on your ship
yeah oh yes there were also three behind
you yeah right there
oh man this game is cool
I know yeah leave this place before
weekend looks like coins carry amaya
sorry from mispronouncing your last name
is a we stream every day at 11:00 we
started a little late today due to some
technical difficulties but hopefully on
Monday we'll have that all sorted out
and by every day I mean Monday through
Friday sorry not Saturday Sunday unless
there's some big thing what are you
gonna get cowboy or oh well Cowboys too
expensive maybe missing one you want to
save yeah no that's silly
Oh God that Crouch is so good
Wow whoa Oh what Ewing you just broke
into their shop and stole them into that
what level are you uh Mario Mike Justice
Mayer have levels no options now okay
it's about language so you can set it to
Japanese although that would do all the
text don't ya
that's that oh I hope so what hot stuff
Silla baby name he wants the poncho it
says yes the poncho definitely it's a
poncho it's got to get one more coin
yes smack them around all day and the
crazy is coupled
oh right oh there we'll go this way
Oh Rob the robot oh yeah possess it whoa
good nice view of everything hey this is
moving up there you can see that one
maybe I don't have a bullet bill can
reach that far but maybe Bullet Bill
there's some bullet bills up there that
you can possess but you can't go up and
down that bullet bill right here it
looks like that might be a better shot
enough you can boost - so you probably
have to get into boost but there's a lot
of moons around here okay
looks like the framerate drops
drastically when the horizon is that it
doesn't seem to us but then I hear that
it's like it's really happening review
the horizon
[Music]
yeah
sorry
Oh ground pound that is tile right there
break it
you see you doing right oh no I
there's another one with you right a
little bit
Kabam
I feel like a lot of this game is just
just paying attention yeah I think
attention the observation which could be
tough to do during the stream
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
hey is gonna look into the stuttering
and see why it's doing that
[Music]
probably
I would do a crowd
ah doesn't for all the music
[Music]
go away
they've had to accelerate yeah now you
gotta get all the way back there though
oh that's not gonna
do that role thing
okay well maybe not
[Music]
another moon there's a moon in there
break all the boxes oh no oh no I can't
I think I wanna ask you though yeah
so alright
so much I seem to miss so many minutes I
bet I've already missed a tumble I know
it's it's crazy how much
[Music]
it reminds me a lot of link between the
worlds you know how they had that like
2d element yeah
[Music]
mm all right
Duncan come oh wait hold on go back down
there and keep running I saw it like
sticking out of those guys
[Music]
[Music]
are using the elder crashing coming down
yeah that's like what I was
go at the logical where there we go I
keep thinking like oh it's gonna then
send me back to the start you get sorry
like especially when you get something
like that yeah when you get like a big
one but now keep going
[Music]
and those guys I love those guys this is
is as far as I got
brakes the blocks that hurts you oh wait
I think you have to jump onto that
platform nice
Oh No Wow still managed to get that
though good work
agency says enjoined the game so far
GameSpot I this is about as far as I've
gotten on my own game and I'm having a
blast with it John Liu yeah yeah yeah
people watching the chat are any of you
guys of the three big games coming out
let's go which one are you playing
they're all pretty good I just be
Wolfenstein yesterday I think realistic
zombi monkey stay is gonna be waiting
gonna be waiting on playing this one for
a while but all it but I look forward to
it
Bob Johnson's I'll get out to see later
20 games I've got right now yeah there
are a lot of games this thing yeah
you want
yeah I guess Dickens what system is this
this is on the Nintendo switch and
zombie monkey says something like he
says I'm actually playing destiny to
Besson around I'm PC with friends all
right yeah that's another big game that
just came out recently
[Music]
but not at the moment cuz he's also
playing Mario right now is that there's
no way he's gonna get that I think my
plans this weekend is I make sure how I
feel inside me give you that as quick as
I can and then spend my like started
running away from you I got again you
think they're like cognizant of what's
happening just possession and they have
no control over it and they're trying to
fight it but it's it's fruitless and a
piece of their soul kind of
[Music]
there's no like pasta forever
all right one more of those charts
[Music]
I know I just turned over
[Music]
so
actually I'm excited houses are speedrun
cuz there'd be like is there like a
there's like any percent speedruns and
there's like a hundred percent speedruns
would you say all I probably say I think
the main lesson
not all of them but like just enough to
beat the game yeah like then like you
can kind of pick which moons you think
are the quickest to get right right like
there's yeah I would like to see two
times people who are like this is the
fastest way is to get your life in the
face and thing yeah here is I got you
just a minute a hell of a memory to
remember where 800 of those things are I
know if I did that I'd surely forget
like 5 like I have no idea where any of
these are people do we're like 64 where
they get like all 120 which is pretty
nuts right yeah 800 just like Assassin's
Creed yeah door down there oh no Mario
Oh oh yeah
go around that back end yeah but there's
more interesting
that looks satisfied by the time we get
back to toast arena town or whatever
we're gonna be able to buy all the all
the clothing first death he says he has
the Triforce tatted on his hand dang
it's insane which a power courage
I put it on the wrong team I don't make
that mistake it's okay yeah I was doing
so well now you're bleeding coins gianlu
completing coin you know you can't do
this
I like get it perfectly it now feels
like there you go you're gonna keep
going hold hold hold
actually that was a dumb idea I
shouldn't have done that okay next time
he messes up I'm gonna catch up cameras
react
he says he was a little tipsy when he
got that
all right
[Music]
oh come on Mario yes I've been feeling
the fans are where you're supposed to go
that's the thing and this is probably a
side thing that's yeah look at that moon
if you can make that I don't think
there's another bunny we should see if
we can get all moons to leave consider
the next areas and then yeah
that's what that list of there is yeah
hopefully it's a new dog city yeah so I
want to see I wanna see the people
walking around
okay
did you ever watch Robot Chicken oh yeah
do you remember that they did a bit
where it was like Mario Jim ta yes and
he was up in a city and everything it
was like Mario Vice City have you ever
seen like the day after they announced
Odyssey and they had that trailer of him
running around city krob krob at I think
it's their name on YouTube made a video
of like they just found a Mario mod
where it replaces Nico they like
recreate the trailer it's so funny it's
maybe one of my favorite guys just keep
watching it it's GUP says what up bros
late start threw me off yes sorry we had
some technical hiccups the motherboard
on the old stream pc just kind of died
so we had to replace it
that's why you're also not seeing a
camera of us right now unfortunately you
also miss that a Dillon in the chat got
a Triforce tattoo on the wrong hands
a little bit tipsy but pretty cool
GUP says mg flame thing oh it's got like
three of them i gotta melt it
but inside here all right what's this
guy doing here though pretty far out
no no going the wrong way the coins
oh well you missed one no I bet there's
something there's a hidden block oh they
had this in a galaxy except not too deep
[Music]
oh oh I like how it goes back to that
one oh yeah does it not do that ingredi
have we seen that before
ah alright wait little late I'm gonna
show a little late on the reaction here
who save is this is John Luke's Dave
he's a little bit farther than I am and
we just started though John the gas did
but I didn't see many responses what do
you guys like today's a big day
Mario you all should get Wolfenstein
because it's really good
it's single players video game without
market transactions
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
[Music]
gube says wolfy times all weekend
starting on death incarnate
I can't talking yesterday about how the
title or when people call the wealthy
times drives us crazy what's that thing
that Mikey sang when he was playing it I
think Aaron kept saying now but Mike
would always say like oh no he'd say
something stupid like that
nope all right back here what do we miss
nothing cool angle though it was just
perfect so I'm gonna keep saying it
awesome
let's get him out of this chat please
I bet you're gonna have to get it
oh I gotta get total gaming interesting
once more how old we are same Mariana
give them points
break all this I remember this exact
part from e3 gameplay
jeez
let's do it this would be a set of three
again or just one
well cars is I wonder what sons are
going to like yeah we've got the same
thing
Miller driven to swing stop is the devil
don't go do it
right
[Music]
[Music]
French is dropping yeah we looks like
we're having some issues hey said he was
gonna try to figure it out we're hoping
by Monday I'll be back
smacking
[Music]
I get toasty the date although I'm not
sure what why would want to know that
you know did we get rid of the cold
maybe because there's that one right
next to us that bundle of three right
[Music]
all right hopefully didn't miss any
moons in that pyramid because it's
floating now let's good point I imagine
you can cook it up there yeah it's
gotten colder
[Music]
alright let's buy some bison clothes
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
coaxes has anyone in the office gotten
almonds yet no although I think being
right by them was very close to getting
all of them yeah I think Peter and
robber the furthest in the office but
they were the only ones who had it
before launching gamespot it was a model
oh I think it's like you put it on your
[ __ ] that's kind of cool
[Music]
all right oh you can go in the
background now go to the end of the town
square
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
go to the end of this and now I'm gonna
left that blue building and talk to this
guy yeah all right
[Music]
awesome that is great oh that's cool
there is another one I think you have to
get on the roof of this building
[Music]
jump on the or the
[Music]
I forgot how I got there down there but
there's like a like a super engine
somewhere around here and there's
you say HD Rumble yeah so I know where
it was for me I wonder if it's different
though it looks like it's different if
you're feeling rumbling they're feeling
some run boy yeah so right now I'm
blinking my left which makes me think
you go left but now it's right
[Music]
[Music]
all right 1 min left yeah let's go to
that uh that taxi dude
nope ready to go sweet awesome oh my god
yeah
I am taxi
[Music]
probably oh you know how ya do it
[Music]
that just wrecked those in this dang
wall do a triple jumps if maybe it's
better
I mean under the shadow Oh Dan yeah I
didn't see I don't know how to get very
dead though welcome back
[Music]
probably needed them guys yeah
only I'd known maybe you can use Bullet
Bill though okay
Oh
so I bet you have to jump out of it oh
my god oh no now you can already like
kill the bunny will they come back dang
it
but I think if you fly under the moon
and jump
oh no Mario
Oh Mario
maybe you can't make that jump
Aiko's like frozen
oh wow look at that Stan you ready just
go deeper and deeper
this looks like a spot for a boss fight
what do you think I would say so the
cars mrs. boss is cool
[Music]
almost an hour and a half now okay maybe
uh yeah
[Music]
yes hahaha
there we go
[Music]
yeah
Oh
[Music]
all right
fairly certain yelling you get them one
more time my knife and drops yeah
all right baguettes there you go moving
around like a pro already
[Music]
Master hands who point out
all bosses take - yeah I was joking
Oh
[Music]
I know all right
burning through them this time
we're not go right between them thread
the needle
[Music]
I guess I have to do I probably like the
jump to avoid that
[Music]
[Music]
tributes James says it's the boss from
tower to gods
I think is that are you referring to the
boss
winwaker the third one I think oh yes it
does seem like him
yeah the shoot the arrows
yes got a punch though
Oh a school boss and he's dead
exploded in fact how many more do we
need we're good oh we're good cool this
yeah after we get this I guess we can go
back to the Odyssey
[Music]
okay gets all the ice is gone working
him in the face oh my god like that uh
jokes are adorable I'm on go amiibo hey
Katie on amiibos they get a finding any
still pounding uh yeah trivia team says
winwaker yes fine
great little sale I know we have two
options
lake kingdom or woody I don't know
chatting chat lake Kingdom or wooded
Kingdom what do you want to see we won't
you won't see much of it no new dog city
though Lake Bob Jones says Lake Lake get
another second I know you tube chats
always behind Taco Bell would it
great we're wooded and Lake third one
third one is the deciding factor oh I
see wooded see another would it - we've
made the right choice open another
wooded yep yeah
isolate Ginga
like lately sorry Bob Jones
how many hours you know many how is it
like Peter to get as far as he did no
idea between this and Assassin's Creed a
lot of game in this weekend yeah yeah I
will I think I'm gonna play it with
abilities but I think I'm gonna try to
finish it when I get my xbox one X yeah
you're getting one of those I'm sure
I'll pick one up at some point probably
the smart idea
oh I'll play a little bit home on my uh
alright this looks like it's from
destiny
yeah that's good
and I'm I'm sure if I was to compare the
X is true for K with the pros
you know checkerboarded for K I'm sure I
could tell the difference if I look at
them side by side but just looking at
out on my own on my 4k TV it looks great
like I I don't feel like I'm necessarily
missing out too much
wait what's dummy stuff you only think
that'd be a huge difference for me is if
say like the X have much much better
frame that would be a more honestly that
game also doesn't really seem to chug
too bad so during some cutscenes yeah
like in game it's fine but then it would
like cut from like a pretty render cuts
into lookin and game cut scene in the
fight we're late checking I know this
these dudes
Bob Jones did you plan horizon in 4k
I did it's really my bet that it looks
really nice step one one the best games
this year
visually I think one of the best games
as well this year in my top 10 yeah so
hard I know I made a pick my own
personal top nd then
spend money oh I want that Explorer 1 :
dr. Mario science advisor let's sign
South but not the doctor I'll quote the
dr. outfit is in the game
all right I'd say that's a pretty good
spot to end thank you guys for tuning
why is he here he shouldn't be here that
great question thank you guys for tuning
in once again were sorry about the
technical difficulties like I said the
motherboard gave out on our old stream
PCs we had to swap that out and that's
why you didn't get the camera the face
camera however hopefully we'll get that
worked out by Monday or sometime next
week but yeah thank you guys for
watching we stream too much every day at
11:00 Monday through Friday and make
sure you subscribe it helps us out and
make sure check out the review for this
game for Wolfenstein for Sasson speed
there's so much stuff going up right now
[Music]